build back better is dead at least for
now nbc news reports that senate
democrats will miss the year-end
deadline
couldn't muster the votes in their own
party to pass the five trillion dollar
spending bill that promised to transform
america
it's hard to overstate you know what
democrats had at stake with buildback
better it was to yes
transform america bringing every
american institution and every american
individual
under the influence and dependence of
democratic spending
but also at stake was their promise to
save america at least in their own minds
and by save america of course i mean
save their reelection chances in 2022
and 2024
and so for three quarters of a year the
sales pitch has been on
we are hard at work on buildback better
which includes so many policies families
need so very much i think billback
better is going to help build this
country back better and we're going to
keep negotiating it's important for us
to get the buildback better act over
the finish line for the american
families to make it in the next year
we have got to make sure the buildback
better is passed
buildback better did not make the finish
line it stumbled right at the ribbon and
its death by the way is good news for
americans why is that
because right now this country is facing
the highest inflation rate it has had in
39 years
and according to a brand new fox
business poll released just an hour ago
it is inflation that is far and away
voters top concern with 84 percent of
americans saying they are either
extremely or very concerned about
inflation that's higher than high crime
rates and coven 19.
and americans know another thing
they know that buildback better would
have been like throwing gasoline on a
fire 46
saying it would have pushed inflation
even higher
but here's what's weird
for so much at stake for democrats with
buildback better they barely seem to
notice its death
they're obsessed right now on capitol
hill and on cable news with their one
true addiction donald trump
they're obsessed with january 6th they
remain on this existential hunt to
justify the six years they lost to their
own insanity and they keep coming back
for another hit on that pipe but
americans have noticed the junky
behavior of the left look at joe biden's
approval rating on everything everything
from the economy to crime and education
low underwater approval rating on almost
every big issue certainly every issue
that concerns americans
but again
here's what's even weirder democrats
sound positively confident
that despite reality a reality that was
quantified in those numbers they sound
confident
they will crush republicans in 2022.
our country could not be more
could not be better served than with
this most experienced capable hands than
yours president biden
he's just perfect the timing couldn't be
better now we look at 2022
i want to tell my republican friends get
ready bal you're going in for a problem
let me say this again for the president
we're going to win in 2022.
get ready pal
joe biden's absolutely perfect
what could justify
that kind of confidence that's a man
that just got dunked on and is
peacocking his feathers on his way back
up the court
well maybe it's because he knows the
next play maybe because democrats know
the next move
build back better may be on the shelf
but that's only until democrats can
clear the way to pass it with zero
resistance we know their playbook well
when they lose the game they work the
ref
when working the ref fails they change
the rules they left that playbook in the
locker room they telegraphed
their game plan
and here is where it starts it starts
with the supreme court senator elizabeth
warren says that a 6-3 conservative
majority quote threatens the foundations
of our nation and she is arguing now
that in order to restore balance and
integrity and she's introducing a bill
to back this up that congress must
expand the court by four seats or more
and obviously those seats will be filled
by liberal justices
but that's just the first step the real
hail mary
is
to start
moving to federalizing elections it's
hard to overstate how big a move the
democrats plan to launch next part of
the reason they shelved buildback better
is so they can shift focus now
to taking over
elections they're looking for a
last-minute push of the freedom to vote
act before the end of the year which
would federalize elections take away
power from states and put it in the
hands of democrats this
is their new year's resolution and last
night joe biden summed it up perfectly
he said the quiet part out loud it's not
about who votes but it's about who
counts the vote
the struggle is no longer just who gets
to vote or making it easy for eligible
people to vote it's about who gets to
count the vote and whether your vote
counts at all
last year we saw one of the most unique
elections in american history we saw a
radical change to how americans voted we
saw male in balloting from coast to
coast and it was absolutely
transformative and the transformation
has only started to begin so now
with almost a smirk on their face
certainly with a lot of confidence
democrats move on to changing the rules
if you can't win the game
change the game hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else